[Music]
mr. vice president we're very honored to
have you here and to have you as the
keynote of our first National Innovation
Summit and we particularly appreciate
the efforts you've made to get here and
flying in open overnight so thank you
very much for being with us
mit clearly is a appropriate site for
this first council initiative on
innovation mit is clearly a national
treasure both as an educational
institution and as a generator of new
knowledge and of course it's
particularly appropriate since Chuck
vest is our Vice Chair of the net of the
Council on competitiveness representing
the academic institutions and I think as
you know mr. vice president this council
is a unique organization it's comprised
of business labor academia leaders of
America really working together to
improve our nation's competitiveness and
from the beginning we have recognized
that government has a key role in in
that as well and we have worked closely
with them and we're very pleased that
the Clinton administration really
recognized this from its beginnings and
has worked closely with us on that now
what brings us here today the members of
the council with the governors and the
congressional issues of both parties as
well as members of the administration is
really a shared belief that the
competitive challenges facing the United
States have changed and are changing a
decade ago the most pressing demands the
face companies like Xerox and many of
our other companies were to reduce costs
to improve quality to shorten our
product life cycles and these really
were the survival issues of that time
but we have made significant progress on
these challenges we as a nation are
significantly more competitive than we
were a decade ago that is documented in
the council's a ten-year report on
competitiveness and we really I believe
have done this by working together with
business
labor academia and a government but we
are now facing a world economy that is
changing very dramatically it's becoming
more integrated the information
revolution has opened new frontiers our
competitive Nations have noticed our
improvement and in fact focused on our
success and have focused on improving
their technology and their innovation
process and as President Clinton and you
have eloquently pointed out it's a new
economy in which is a higher premium and
than ever on translating new ideas into
new products and services that will win
in the global markets and support high
wages at home ladies and gentlemen no
one in public life has taken a more
visible role and lead than the Vice
President Gore in trying to understand
and respond to the new forces at work
his interest and knowledge of technology
and innovation process I think it's well
known to all of us but I think many of
us would be surprised at the depth of
his knowledge and I've had this pointed
out to me a couple times both in the
early days when he was vice
president-elect at the economic summit
in Little Rock but even more clearly one
time with the council that sponsored
with the Library of Congress a small
conference on the internet and the
implications of the Internet and this
was attended by a number of CEOs a
number of government leaders and a
number of technologists and I know
speaking for a number of CEOs in the
audience given the dialogue between the
technologists and the vice president we
all went home and said we better get
another tutorial on the internet because
he clearly knows a lot more than we do
about that mr. vice president as you
know we are discussing in will discuss
more today the ten-year outlook for u.s.
innovation and the action steps that
could position could strengthen our
position in this regard and we are very
fortunate that our dialogue will be
informed by your perspective and of
course we hope to continue to
engage you in a concerted effort after
this innovation conference to strengthen
our country and strengthen our nation
ladies and gentlemen the Vice President
Al Gore thank you very much no please
thank you thank you very much thank you
ladies and gentlemen thank you very much
for your kindness and Paul thank you for
your very generous introduction I've
really enjoyed working with you over the
years and I want to say what a personal
debt I owe to Paul elaire for being my
tutor when I began the reinventing
government project for President Clinton
and he and a few others came and gave me
some lessons that were absolutely
invaluable in getting that started and I
want to acknowledge the other leaders of
of this summit here this meeting Chuck
vest is a longtime friend and
outstanding president of this
institution bill hamberg chairman of the
council and John yochelson a President
of the Council on competitiveness George
Fisher a chairman and CEO of the Eastman
Kodak I was just looking at iridium
latest project progress yesterday from
his former company John Young the
founder of the council who's met with
President Clinton and me on so many
occasions and serves as a co-chair of
the President's Council on science and
technology advisors and Jack Shankman
the vice chair of the council
representing the perspective of labor
and Sandy Fellman who is is here from
the aft and a great friend and an ally
and also to the members of Congress who
were here I want to acknowledge my
friend Nancy Pelosi Vernon Ahlers and my
former colleagues on the Science and
Technology Committee
Sensenbrenner and George Brown who I see
through the lights here I see Jim and
George is here somewhere over here I
served on the House Science and
Technology Committee for eight years and
learned a lot from these two gentlemen
and we work together to form a
bipartisan support of base of support
for research and development and
measures to improve the competitiveness
of our country and it's great to to see
them here too governor Zell Miller of
Georgia and governor John Engler of
Michigan thank you too very much
I'll have another of reference to
governor Miller in in a moment I want to
especially thank Dan Goldin who as you
heard from his presentation a moment ago
is a real visionary and he and I have
worked together since I presided over
his confirmation hearings when I was on
the Senate science subcommittee part of
the Senate Commerce Committee and back
in the last administration and we have
had a wonderful working relationship and
he does a truly outstanding job and I
want to acknowledge our former secretary
of defense bill Perry who's around here
somewhere and a great partner and friend
and there are all kinds of other
distinguished guests I probably ought to
to acknowledge but I don't know too to
do it without accidentally missing
people so I'll just go right on to what
I have to say here and I'd like to start
that by telling you what a pleasure it
is to be back with the Council on
competitiveness and it's great to be
back here at MIT I haven't spoken here
in almost two years it'll be two years
ago June when I was asked to give the
commencement address I really enjoyed
that and I told the story at that time
about a great tragedy that occurred when
the founder of MIT after 20 years after
his retirement came back in 1882 to
deliver the commencement address and
it's a true story right in the middle of
his speech he dropped dead
now you see you're laughing but as
terrible as that is I was I noted then I
was comforted by the fact that no matter
how I performed I would be remembered as
only the second stiffest speaker in the
history of those commencement addresses
and I can't I can't get away from that I
you know the Academy Awards are coming
up and the Good Will Hunting which takes
place at MIT is among the nominees
anyway last year when they had the
Academy Awards it made a real impression
on me because my wife tipper and I were
propped up on pillows in the bed
watching the telecast and Billy Crystal
the host came out with to start the show
with a an Oscar on the podium and he
mentioned that there were so many people
nominated and only a few would win he
cautioned them against disappointment
and he looked right into the camera and
he said remember the only person who's
guaranteed to wake up tomorrow morning
with a statue is tipper gore
[Laughter]
as Groucho Marx once said I resemble
that remark anyway I'm very grateful to
this Council on competitiveness for
convening this critical national summit
and very grateful for the important work
you have done for so long and especially
during this past year because you've
been helping us understand the dramatic
changes that are taking place throughout
our economy and throughout our society
not only in the United States but
throughout the world and as someone with
a longtime interest in innovation and
it's considerable economic benefits I
have followed the work of this council
since its founding a dozen years ago you
all came back when others were in your
positions now and testified before our
House Science and Technology Committee
and Jim and George and I had
interchanges back then you've shaped
policy for a long time
I remember in chairing the Senate
science subcommittee we frequently had
testimony from this council and over the
years like water on stone you have worn
away some of the resistance you
encountered at first and we've still got
a ways to go as a nation as you continue
to point out very forcefully but we are
making some changes and under President
Clinton's leadership we've seen some
pretty significant changes but the
fundamental reality remains our economy
is now driven by innovation and as
Michel Porter's that talk and study
pointed out other nations are really
moving rapidly to take advantage of the
new ability to innovate that is out
there we are
obviously at the dawn of a true
innovation age it's almost a cliche to
point out the sequence from agriculture
to industry to information but the
change is accelerating
consider these facts it's estimated that
the entire store of human knowledge now
doubles every five years for example
we're just a few years away from the
complete sequencing of the human genome
giving us for the very first time a kind
of instruction manual for the human body
when that human genome is completed it
will have a gestalt effect the whole
will be considerably larger and more
important than the sum of its parts
just as the internet when it was
completed to the point where everyone
could connect into it acquired a
significance far larger than the
incremental advance that completed the
last accessibility in the same way we're
going to see a whole revolution in
genetics and biotechnology even beyond
what is going on right now when the
human genome is finally completed and
it's so it's so close within a couple of
years microchips will routinely contain
1 billion transistors per chip the size
of a fingernail and the patterns etched
onto them will be as complex and
complicated as the roadmap for the
entire planet
that's difficult to comprehend and the
implications are of course vast I
mentioned iridium from George's old
company within six months I think
they've got 42 satellites up now the
constellation of 66 will be rounded out
in early September they'll have a couple
of weeks of a shake out time by the end
of September this year
it will be possible to make a cell
cellular telephone call from any point
on the surface of this planet to any
other point on the surface of this
planet and soon after there will be
multiple competing systems offering the
same service within three years it will
be possible to receive from
any point on the surface of this planet
information flows of six-and-a-half
gigabits compared to like 36 million
bits necessary for faxes and pagers and
telephone service it will be possible to
get six and a half gigabits six and a
half billion bits of information flowing
down remotely Wireless to any place on
the surface of the earth what that means
is that access to the information
superhighway will be available from the
sands of the Kalahari from the top of
Mount Everest from any place on the
surface of the earth now what are the
implications obviously they're so vast
that it's impossible to predict what
that will happen nobody could predict
all of the changes that flowed from the
invention of the printing press and the
ubiquitous availability of information
to average citizens when books could be
printed when it's possible to have full
internet access for all of the five and
a half by then six almost six billion
people on on this planet the the
consequences are going to be really
staggering we're on the verge of
fulfilling a vision outlined by a
Nathaniel Hawthorne in the middle of the
last century 15 years after the
invention of the Telegraph he wrote
these words by means of electricity the
world of matter has become a great nerve
vibrating thousands of miles in a
breathless point of time the round globe
is a vast brain instinct with
intelligence often it's easy to chart
the exact benefits of a new breakthrough
to our health care to our pocketbooks to
our hard disk drives but today I'd like
to briefly talk about innovation in a
broader context and to talk about
innovation not merely as a material goal
but as an ethic a constant concern a
continuing focus for our entire country
some of you
as managers are familiar with the the
phrase learning organization some of you
manage toward that objective we as a
nation must be a learning nation we have
to put into place the infrastructure the
policies the programs and the habits
that enable us to continue innovating at
an accelerating rate mi t--'s mato men's
at manis mind and hand sums up this
challenge true innovation encompasses
not only the labor of our hands but also
the labor of our minds increasingly of
course brain replaces brawn and if
American industry is to continue growing
and thriving and remaining competitive
we must be willing to think and act anew
to keep pushing the boundaries of
knowledge and discovery and to reshape
our economy by redefining the way we
view our world Thomas Kuhn wrote a
path-breaking study many years ago about
the way revolutions in thought occur all
of a sudden new observations new
findings about the world don't fit into
the old models that we're using and then
slowly these unexplainable observations
accumulate to the point where the old
model doesn't work anymore and then all
of a sudden someone comes up with an
innovative new pattern that explains the
UH the previously unexplainable and
produces a new vision into which all of
the information that was mysterious in
the past fits neatly at a few precious
moments in our history we see this occur
in a dramatic way more than 500 years
ago a Columbus set sail and obviously by
discovering the new world he gave us a
new vision of Earth Copernicus was 19
years old when Columbus landed in the
New World and
just a few years after that just a
couple of decades after that rather he
produced the new model explaining not
only the earth but its relationship to
the solar system in a new way a century
after Columbus Galileo first turned the
new instrument of the telescope toward
the sky and shattered centuries-old
notions about the mechanics of our solar
system and obviously the I mean I saw a
cartoon recently maybe it was in the
Wall Street Journal about with the
Columbus speaking to Queen Isabella and
saying and not only will we find spices
this will create 3,000 new jobs and I
you know I think sometimes we we sound
like that a little bit and for obvious
reasons but the discoveries coming out
of the Age of Exploration unleashed the
greatest explosion of trade and commerce
the the world had ever seen new lands
brought new ideas and the need for new
inventions Europe's contact with other
cultures and customs while not always
mutually positive stimulated new
thinking in the old world now half a
millennium after Columbus in our time we
broke free from the gravitational pull
of the earth with the Apollo program and
we went to explore the surface of the
Moon but in doing so we dramatically
change the way we viewed ourselves and
our own planet dan knows that in in my
office in the in the White House my
office is down the hall from the Oval
Office I I work in the famous square
office in the in the White House and on
the on the wall is a is a photograph of
the earth that was taken on December 7th
by the very last Apollo mission to the
moon it is the most printed photograph
in the history of humankind the people
who keep up with those things say the
next closest photograph is not even
close I remember when the Apollo 8
mission first circled the moon before
Apollo 11 landed and the image of the
Earth from space had a dramatic impact
some people anticipated that the great
british astrophysicist Fred Hoyle
predicted in 1948 in these words once a
photograph of the Earth taken from
outside is available once the sheer
isolation of the earth becomes plain a
new idea as powerful as any in history
will be let loose of course it wasn't
until the Apollo missions exactly 20
years later that we found out the truth
of that prophecy like a child's first
glimpse of herself in a mirror those
photographs changed our own self-image
we saw a world that was not as vast or
expansive or incomprehensible as we had
thought but surprisingly smaller more
interconnected and more fragile the poet
Archibald MacLeish wrote of those images
to see the earth as we see it now small
and blue and beautiful in that eternal
silence where it floats is to see
ourselves as writers on the earth
together brothers on the bright
loveliness in the unending night
brothers who see now they are truly
brothers this new image this new way of
integrating knowledge shifted centuries
of human understanding and brought about
dramatic results certainly such a
quantum leap in our worldview does not
occur all that often but when it does it
sometimes
takes decades to know where the leap is
taking us and in that spirit it's not
that different from the work that many
of you do each and every day pushing the
ever-expanding boundaries of knowledge
and discovery creating and innovating
for the ultimate benefit of all of our
people at its heart what innovation
means is looking at the world in new and
different ways our challenge is to
create the right climate for that kind
of innovation both large and small and
to harness its enormous economic
potential for the 21st century
you've already come a long way and with
help from so many of you our nation is
building a new economy one that takes
innovation as its starting point not as
a mere byproduct the new economy is
driven by innovation information and
Technology are its fuels the new economy
values the productivity and creativity
of people above all else
yesterday I had long sessions in Silicon
Valley with the Prime Minister of Russia
Viktor Chernomyrdin and the CEOs of many
of the leading high technology firms
some of you all couldn't be there
because you were on your way here for
this for this meeting bill Perry was one
in that category bill Hambrick there's
some others but we had quite a
representation from the high tech
community there and they made it plain
to the leadership of Russia what we
already know which is that by far the
most valuable resource or asset that any
nation has is the unused creativity and
brainpower of the men and women in that
nation Russia has more PhDs per capita
than any nation on the face of this
earth
you talk about an innovation policy they
need one and we do too and there there
are a lot of things that it is now
obvious with this new world view we need
to be doing right now
the new economy is connected to the
global marketplace where we zap dollars
and date around the world at the speed
of light now today we do have some
things going for us the American economy
is once again the envy of the world
interest rates and inflation are at
record lows investment and modernization
are both rising we have 15 million new
jobs the lowest unemployment in a
generation and today a full third of our
GDP growth now comes from information
technology our fast-growing
environmental technology industry is
already bigger than our steel industry
textile industry or aerospace industry
more Americans build semiconductors now
than construction machinery more
Americans spend their days processing
data than refining petroleum more
Americans now build computers than build
cars perhaps more importantly today
there is left less difference between
the task of building a computer and
building a car open up a car and it
doesn't look a lot different than some
computers today's Ford Taurus has more
computing power than those Apollo
spacecraft in the 1960s and and 70s and
those that build cars do so in ways that
emphasize quality performance and
innovation part of what we used to call
and some still call the Japanese
challenge came about because they
figured out how to innovate new
generations of products like cars in a
much shorter period of time they they
took the lead time from the idea for a
new car from that point to the
appearance of the new car from seven
years down to five years down to three
years and there's a great race on now to
get that process down to two one year
some of the technologies that Dan Goldin
referred to will be important in that
process already in the aircraft
manufacturing industry Boeing is leading
the entire world because it has figured
out how to use some of the new
information technologies to
impress that development period down to
the bare minimum the triple seven as
many of you know was created without any
paper to speak off completely in digital
form and the maintenance can be done
digitally as well their telescoping that
lead time from idea to the appearance of
the product really across the board and
our own automobile industries companies
are are now on the verge of creating the
largest most powerful extra net in in
the world to connect with their
suppliers and subcontractors and move
toward digital paperless information
flows in the development of new vehicles
we are working with the big three in the
partnership for a new generation of
vehicles to move beyond the internal
combustion engine toward a new
generation of vehicles that will have
much higher levels of efficiency will be
much more cost competitive with much
lower levels of pollution among the
other advantages now these two examples
illustrate the convergence of
technologies that is now giving us the
ability to get productivity gains from
computers long after their initial
introduction we know from history that
sometimes innovations are exciting and
obviously important but don't bring any
measurable improvements in productivity
for quite some time some of you are
familiar with the example of what
happened when new electric motors were
invented and introduced people thought
that they would bring improvements in
productivity but they didn't at least
not for a while why but
cause the context into which they were
introduced had not changed in order to
accommodate the new potential the old
factories from the Industrial Age were
designed for steam engines and that
meant that many of them were highly
highly vertical with conveyor belts and
loops coming off the the central source
of power in the middle of the factory
when they retrofitted factories like
that with small electric motors the
inherent efficiencies in the electric
motors couldn't be seen anywhere but
over time that those physical plants
wore out new factories were built and
designed in a way that accommodated the
inherent efficiencies of that new
technology and so after a long delay all
of a sudden there was a surge in
productivity because the inherent
advantages were able to be expressed in
the new context that was created I think
we're seeing something exactly like that
now with the delayed productivity gains
from the introduction of micro
processors and computers and networks as
businesses and industries now redesign
their physical plants and more
importantly their processes and their
human interactions in ways that take
advantage of the new abilities conferred
by micro processing that's why I
sometimes wonder about the measurements
that are used on innovation and
productivity we have to make do with
what measurements so we can get our
hands on but this is inherently a very
inexact process and those of you who've
spent a long time studying productivity
know that it's just
the studies are just a mess they're just
so many factors involved and some people
will have great precision and saying
this or that about it and and we again
we have to work with the information
available but sometimes you can
introduce some new capacities that you
know we're gonna fuel a surge in
productivity even if it's not measured
for a while look at the Internet when we
started providing seed money in the
Congress more than 20 years ago for the
development of what is now the internet
there was there was no enthusiasm in the
business community for it because it was
it was not relevant to the way business
operated at the time now of course every
business has its own web page and whole
industries are being redesigned in order
to take full advantage of the abilities
of the Internet when President Clinton
and I took office there were only 50
sites on the world wide web that hadn't
been that long ago just five little over
five years ago and now of course
millions and millions and the increase
is geometric it is some it is an example
of a new capacity a new way of linking
together a new convergence a new way of
seeing the world that after a delay
produces a surge of productivity in fact
if you think back on that example of the
electric motors what happened there was
when alternating current was invented it
made it made it possible to distribute
electricity over a much wider area and
and then it was possible with electric
motors to distribute the sources of
mechanical energy throughout the factory
and co-locate them precisely where each
machine needed the mechanical energy in
exactly that same way
what the internet is making possible is
a new form of distributed intelligence
distributed knowledge distributed
information and all of the old
organizational structures which like
those vertical factories based on the
steam engines relied on a central
repository for knowledge with all the
decisions having to go to that central
place now the knowledge is distributed
widely and easily and geographic
boundaries are not as significant as
they once were Microsoft has a contract
in India for maintenance and service so
that when you call the number they may
take care of it in Seattle or without
knowing it you may be talking to someone
in in India over the internet and
receiving the information seamlessly as
if it was coming from Redmond Washington
and of course many of you here could
give similar examples but the point is
today's technology is allowing us to
unlock a much higher fraction of that
unused creativity among men and women
all over our nation and we're able to
reach out to those who in previous years
would have been left out of the world of
innovation now we never know where we
will find the person responsible for the
next intellectual breakthrough it could
be a janitor right here at MIT you can't
you can't ever tell some of you saw the
movie
there's simply no question that if we
want to make the most of the 21st
century and this new economy if we want
to achieve the full promise of American
business we have to do everything we can
to fuel new innovation and discovery
build partnerships that encourage
support and reward cutting-edge ideas
and keep our economy strong enough and
efficient enough to take advantage of
them as quickly as possible along with
my colleague
I've worked on initiatives to try to
take advantage of these new realities
the Small Business Innovation research
initiative the first legislation which
led to the internet the first funding
for the Human Genome Project and the
rest and over the past five years under
President Clinton's leadership we have
done an enormous amount to encourage
innovation for a for a quarter of a
century the number of patent
applications for inventions by Americans
hovered between 60,000 and 70,000 per
year that was true for most of the 1980s
the past few years have seen that number
jump up to above 100,000 similarly we've
increased the number of patent awards by
50 percent from the early 1980s we plan
to seize that promise by continuing the
bold new economic strategy that we
believe is partly responsible for the
surge of strength in the new economy
eliminating the deficit opening up new
markets to our products and investing
more in education technology job
training and Environmental Protection
and other efforts which help to secure
our future on the first point we will
balance the budget and will we will do
it this year the budget the president
just proposed to Congress takes the
deficit that used to have 1100 that is
very important when you look at access
to credit it's an old story to describe
what it was like for companies to
compete in credit markets with the
800-pound gorilla that had to get 300
billion dollars a year or more in order
to finance the federal deficit so we
made tough choices based on hard numbers
and freed up hundreds of billions of
dollars in capital to finance private
investments including research and
development and one of the other reasons
for our emphasis on eliminating the
deficit is not only the competition in
credit markets but also the simple fact
that in this new economy we're not on
the gold standard we're on the
information standard and we get a
Premium in-world credit markets and
finance markets when they see that the
economy is being managed well investment
capital is flowing toward the United
States we're seeing an expression of
confidence all over the world in US
markets we need to go further and
increase the savings rate that's a very
complicated challenge as your council
has made clear over the years but we
must do our best to meet that challenge
now the second component of our economic
strategy after having a sound fiscal
policy is to keep on opening markets for
American products overseas ninety-six
percent of the consumers in the world
live in other countries that's why we've
signed more than 200 new trade
agreements in the past few years and
we're pushing hard for the authority to
enter into yet more trade agreements
we're also aggressively addressing
unfair trade practices by other nations
we're insisting upon the protection of
intellectual property rights I just had
lengthy discussions with Prime Minister
Chen immured and over the last three
days so for example on that point and
we're putting in place mechanisms to
help to address the concerns of at-risk
workers as we move ever farther into
this global marketplace the third part
of our economic strategy is making those
targeted investments in the future and
that means first and foremost
dramatically improving our K through 12
education system and that's why we're
after hiring a hundred thousand new
police officers to help bring the crime
rate down we're now proposing measures
to hire a hundred thousand new
high-quality teachers to reduce
classroom sizes that's why we're trying
to connect every single classroom and
library to the information superhighway
that's why we're trying to finance the
construction and renovation of crumbling
classrooms and school buildings all over
the United States that's why we're
pushing national standards for for math
and reading that's why we're setting
specific national goals that's why we're
calling for voluntary now
channel tests you can ask any classroom
of students whether or not they study
harder if they know the test is coming
up and the answer is of course yes well
if we have tests against which we can
measure progress or the lack of progress
we're gonna have an easier time figuring
out whether we're moving in the right
direction or whether we're moving in the
wrong direction we have to invest in the
improvements to our education system
we've already freed up more money for
access to higher education than at any
time since the passage of the GI Bill oh
and we we are addressing the problems in
our job training system we've called as
part of the initial reinventing
government report we call for the
elimination of all of the various and
complicated job training programs and
the replacement of all of them with a
voucher system - to really streamline
the job training marketplace I want to
say that I encourage every single one of
you to look closely at an innovation
that Governor Zell Miller has put in
place in Columbus Georgia called the
ipact mechanism that brings together
universities community leaders and the
business community to dramatically
change higher education in a technical
school format to produce highly relevant
sophisticated skills that are
immediately redeemable in the
marketplace it is the single most
innovative model that I have seen and of
course we took the HOPE scholarship
model from Governor Miller now we're
stealing this from him we're trying to
give him credit for it like we did the
hope scholarships but I really encourage
you all to look at that now investing in
the future also means investing in
research and development that's why
we're proposing the 21st century
Research Fund to have the largest
increases by far in funding for the
National Science Foundation the National
Institutes of Health and National Cancer
Institute and our other research
institutions that we've ever had in
American has
we believe that in the innovation age
basic research must be financed by the
people of this country through the
institutions of self-government simply
because of the obvious reason that
for-profit enterprises because of
competition are necessarily going to
have to focus on research that has more
immediate applications and that's why
we're investing not just in targeted
research but also in the undirected
research that often yields the largest
long-term gains of course that it takes
private sector investment as well and we
have to understand that even though
there are new efficiencies and research
and development with computational
science and the Internet the new
advantages that supercomputers give
still the basic cost for research and
development are increasing and so we've
proposed an extension of America's two
point two billion dollar research and
experimentation Tax Credit which is
critical to our most innovative
industries and we're encouraging other
policies that free up more funding for
private research and development now
part of our strategy is also to
unshackle the dynamism of the new
economy by freeing it from the heavy
hand of old outdated obsolete government
practices I've referred a couple of
times to a reinventing government I'll
give you a couple of examples
we're fighting to streamline the patent
law and we've proposed to take the
patent office and make it what we call a
performance-based organization to get
rid of the bureaucracy of the past the
red tape the regulations have a CEO have
performance measures have strict
accountability set it up as a
performance based organization and let
it go we think by focusing on results
and giving increased flexibility to a
managers and making other specific
changes we can bring about the kind of
transformation in government
organizations that many of you have
brought about in your private companies
already we have
reduce the size of the federal
government by 350,000 people in the last
five years it is now smaller in size
than it has been since 1961 the first
year of President John Kennedy's
administration and it's smaller as a
percentage of the workforce than it was
since before the New Deal we've
eliminated 200 outdated government
programs eliminated more than 16,000
pages of red tape saved 137 billion
dollars in the process but we need
further improvements in regulatory
reform and in legal reform we need to
advance rapidly by using these new
understandings and new techniques now
we're paying special attention to the
growth and development of the Internet
we believe that the new economy is in
many ways an internet economy we have an
aggressive strategy to foster electronic
commerce trade and commerce on the
Internet are now tripling every year and
in just a few years we will be
generating hundreds of billions of
dollars in the sales of goods and
services we want to ensure the
establishment of an environment in which
electronic commerce can grow and
flourish so that every computer can be a
window open to every business large and
small everywhere in the world that means
minimal government no new taxes and no
cumbersome regulation that's why we're
working to make the internet a global
free trade zone to take advantage of its
full potential for stimulating
prosperity and our 21st century research
fund invests hundreds of millions of
dollars to help speed up the development
of the next generation internet which
will have data flows more than a
thousand times greater than the present
Internet and soon after that we will
increase it by another thousandfold just
imagine what the next generation can
help us achieve with data moving a
thousand times faster and having that
wireless access all over the globe just
three years from now I believe this
overall approach is one that will
definitely improve America's future
competitiveness and I wish to give
credit
to this council for generating many of
the the basic ideas upon which our
strategy has been based this dialogue
you've been having with our nation over
the last dozen years has really been
paying off and I encourage you to
continue the kind of forward thinking
that you have been up to before I close
I'd like to say that today I would want
to issue a specific challenge that I
hope will advance the discovery process
and give us a little bit richer
understanding of the world that we
inhabit I referred at the beginning of
my speech to Columbus's voyage according
to historians a Spanish sailor named
rodrigo de Triana was standing in the
forecastle of the Pinta Columbus's ship
and was the first person to see the new
world today a clearer view of our own
world could help us reach new heights of
understanding and that's why today I'm
proposing that NASA launched a satellite
named Triana which will provide the very
first continuous live images of the
entire Earth from space it will bring
into the digital age those remarkable
pictures we received of our earth a
generation ago you know that picture I
referred to was taken 26 years ago there
hasn't been one since then actually
there was for a brief moment a short
video of the earth as the Galileo
spacecraft was speeding away from the
earth and it turned around and focused
it kept its cameras on the earth and for
just a few seconds we were able to see
for just a short time I should say when
it was speeded up that the film is very
short but then it was gone and the
reason we don't have any other pictures
is that images from Earth orbit even
from the geosynchronous orbit 22,300
miles
I just allows us to see a tiny part of
the Earth's surface the angle interferes
with our ability to see the entire
planet as you would from that simulated
view I'd like to show this video
illustrating the the idea behind this
satellite that I'm challenging NASA to
launch the first picture in this video
is the one that I described from
December of 1972 on the Apollo 17
mission you can see Antarctica at the
bottom it's the last picture we've had
of the earth except as I mentioned for
this brief stunning imagery as the
Galileo spacecraft left the earth
wouldn't it be nice to have that image
continuous live 24 hours a day we can
understand weather systems better if we
do now we'll be able to with this
project which will launch this small
satellite from the space shuttle bay
that's one of the options and then it
will be sped toward a point in space
between beyond the moon between the
earth and the Sun the Sun as you know is
96 million miles away 1 million miles
from the earth just shy of that there is
a point called the l1 point where the
gravitational fields of the Earth and
Sun cancel each other out and this
satellite can be positioned there to
focus a high-definition television
camera on the earth and send images down
to students by way of the internet we'll
be able to study the movement of weather
systems in a brand-new way understanding
our understanding of phenomena like El
Nino can be vastly improved if we can
see farther into the Pacific Ocean where
the storms develop this is a this is a
imagery that is very difficult to piece
together from the current weather
satellites the this that's digitally
stitched together from a lot of
different geosynchronous weather
satellites it'll come down to three
university-based earth stations and then
made available worldwide through the
internet and the
which will take place in less than two
years if this is successful we will have
live 24-hour a day coverage of the earth
within less than two years I believe
that this can have tremendous scientific
value and help us to understand the
emergence of global weather patterns and
help us in a lot of other ways as
Socrates said 2,500 years ago man must
rise above the earth to the top of the
atmosphere and beyond for only thus will
he fully understand the world in which
he lived in different words a former
friend of some of us here the astronaut
rusty Schweickart once described what he
felt during the Apollo a series when he
was orbiting the moon and he said you
realize that on that small spot that
little blue and white thing is
everything that matters to you all of
history and music and poetry and art and
war and death and birth and love tears
joy games all of it is on that little
spot out there that you can cover with
your thumb with triana that same
experience could be available to all of
us and as Columbus's reputed to have
said it will also produce 3,000 jobs
Daniel Boorstin the great former
librarian of Congress wrote the most
promising words ever written on the maps
of human knowledge are terra incognita
unknown territory that's true of our
ability to understand the earth our
effort to understand the new economy
it's true of your efforts to understand
how we can stimulate more innovation in
the United States of America I'm proud
to say that President Clinton and I are
ready and willing partners in the effort
to stimulate more innovation in the US
economy we will do everything we can to
keep
growth and innovation high and
productivity strong so let us continue
to blaze new paths to American
competitiveness continue to search for
uncharted territories be they near or
far and in the spirit of this great
institution let us apply our hands and
our minds and our hearts to that
endeavor for that is how we will build a
21st century and the new economy of our
dreams thank you very much
[Applause]